this series is brought to you by Globe
planets welcome back to the very last
episode in this twin motion tutorial
today we're going to be running you
through exactly how to create images
videos and how to export them so let's
dive straight in down the bottom you're
going to see the little media icon if
you hit the media button straight away
you're going to get another doc open up
I've gone ahead and created three images
which I will go now head and delete so
that we can start fresh and all start on
same page first thing you want to do is
just go ahead and hit that plus button
to create your first scene we have
discussed this before but we're going to
go through it in a little bit more
detail this time so let's start by going
into our camera selecting our focal
length that we're happy with in this
instance
35 mil works really really well it gives
you a nice crop it gives you a nice
composition so we can use 35 millimeters
camera effects there's not too much to
worry about except maybe power realism
being turned on and composition overlays
turning our grids just to double check
where we are in this grid after that we
can refresh our scene make sure that we
are resetting our image to this exact
position turn off the composition and
head to our environment I always like to
turn auto exposure off in my renders to
be able to have full control over the
scene so adjusting your exposure ever so
slightly to be able to create the
perfect image for that moment you can go
through each one of these individual
items and Sliders as we discussed in a
previous tutorial to be able to get a
better render at the end of the day and
of course you should keep your hdri sky
on to be able to get the best results
once you've gone through all of the data
and all the settings you of course want
to increase your format to as large as
humanly possible and then repeat the
same steps over and over so simply fly
around the building fly around the scene
and find new creative angles where you
want to export a render so let's pretend
we want a secondary render from here hit
that plus button we get a new image
continue to fly around to the
potentially the opposite side of this
building from the human scale once again
hit the plus button when you're happy
with the composition same concept
applies internally of course if we fly
inside our building rotate around we can
look out potentially back at our own
building from our bedroom
hit that plus button and then we want to
adjust our actual camera and our focal
length so if we slide this wider we'll
get to see a lot more what's going on at
15 mil we get the full bedroom we get
all of the outside and then we can
refresh it for that focal length now if
we go back into our project and fly to a
different space
hit that plus button once more we will
keep those camera settings we used from
our last image if you want the camera
settings from a previous image just
double click back on that image and then
fly to your next desired image location
once you're there hit the plus button
the new image will jump to the end and
then you will create it using the old
settings now I've gone through that
relatively quickly because we've
discussed all of this in a previous
video what we haven't discussed is video
content creation and how to export so if
we hit quit Media mode come across the
top to our video creation and press
video we can start creating our first
video of course you have Panorama
multiple panoramas a presentation mode
and a phasing group all of these are a
bit more advanced especially the phasing
Group which allows you to basically
create time lapses if things moving so
we won't dive into that in this tutorial
now if you've ever asked yourself what
is the difference between high quality
render and an average render you see all
over Instagram well the difference is
the quality the care and the assets
that's why I've teamed up with globe
plants to be able to give you an
incredible library of the world's best
3D photorealistic vegetation trees
shrubs and everything in between are
these Globe plans for a very long time
now you've seen them in my videos before
and finally we've come together to be
able to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plants in the
description down below the link is there
for your convenience to create a video
on the other hand It's relatively simple
and the same concept we just spoke about
for photo so first of all you want to
align and set up your first video press
that plus button to be able to get the
settings tab open run through these
settings make sure they're exactly as
you want them so turning on a hdri sky
adjusting our Auto exposure manually
adjusting that to where we see fit
adjusting little parts and of course our
camera focal length until we're happy
flying back around until the perfect
angle is found to commence our video
next we want to refresh that scene to
capture it and save it now we want to
fly to our second scene imagining it as
if the camera was moving in that
direction gliding per se more so than
anything so if we were to fly over to
the right hand side of this building and
Center in the frame back over in our
ocean let's say we're happy here in the
Middle with our second scene we then
want to click the plus button next to
the last frame by selecting that plus
button it will instruct the camera to
move from part one to frame two in a
very gentle motion you hit play and it
will slowly Glide that video across to
exactly that second frame you've
selected if you wish to continue the
camera movement from point A to point B
and thus to point C you would simply
continue along down to your next scene
capture where you are happy with the
general camera angle hit that plus
button once again and then if you go
back to scene 1 press play firstly it
will fly quicker because there are more
scenes to complete in the 10 second time
frame and secondly it will fly from
point A to point B to point C I
mentioned this just in case you do not
want to fly from point B to point C and
you want to jump to point C and then to
a different point D I'll explain that in
a second what you also saw is this video
was a lot quicker because there was more
Saints and the more scenes you add the
quicker the video will continue to be so
to slow down the camera motion you need
to slow down or increase depending on
what you're looking for the video time
stamp so if I increase that to 30
seconds press play it will once again
further slow down and gently Glide
across this architectural design now
like I said if we didn't want to jump
from point C to let's say Point D over
here which might be looking at one of
these flowers in detail and that
beautiful cantilever if I simply click
the plus button I would be flying from
from point C to point D and it would do
this awkward wrapping motion something
that I don't particularly want so
instead I'm going to delete that last
scene I'm going to fly back over to my
flower of course courtesy of globe
plants who is a sponsor of today's video
fly into a little bit of detail with the
building in the background and instead
of pressing the plus button down here
I'm going to press a new video part Plus
you'll see that a secondary part 2 has
been created and then I can slowly fly
around zoom into my flower press my
second plus watch the motion fly very
gently from part one to part two and
then if I was to jump back to the
original Part B in the middle or the
second frame press play let that
eventually slowly get through to the end
of the third frame you'll see it doesn't
naturally move to the flower it
automatically jump Cuts so here you'll
see in three two one it jumps
immediately to that flower
then to repeat that same step let's say
we wanted another jump cut really
focusing on those Globe plants down the
bottom as well as the building in the
background we could once again hit that
plus get a third video apart slowly pan
across onto this beautiful Grass Tree
press the plus once fly to our second
space press the plus again and now when
we watch that scene play through we'll
fly through the grass we'll fly through
the flowers towards the grass tree
slowly isolate and then spin around
of course we can reduce the speed of
that by changing that down to 30 seconds
and then from point A to point B it'll
again continue to slow down and give it
a lot more depth and texture
now I have decreased my settings here in
my preferences to medium quality but if
I bump that back up to Ultra you would
see the increased texture on all of
these Globe plans features so if I press
play you'll see that beautiful stunning
flower in full detail with the
cantilever in the background of course
my computer isn't that powerful to
handle all of these polygons hence why I
reduce it down in quality to medium and
I'm happy for the export to be 100
perfect and not worry about what it
looks like in Twin motion now once
you've gone through and created your
scene you've created your video you can
actually make most of the video here in
Twin motion without having the need to
put it into Premiere Pro and cut it all
up which is phenomenal you get your
timeline here straight away you can then
go down to export now export has all of
your exports in one go
personally I like to recommend exporting
your videos first or your images first
and then the other that way once your
images are exported you can work on them
whilst the video is exporting and you
don't have to wait around for both to
finish so if let's click on our Plus for
the images select all of our images to
export if we then click on the image
itself it will drop down a menu for
three different file formats as well as
details
file format is completely up to what you
guys want to use PNG jpeg completely
fine and acceptable in most cases xcr
I've never personally used but I'm sure
somebody has a use case for it motion
blur works really well if you have paths
created for vehicles and cars so it
creates the motion however I haven't
created any of that in this tutorial so
we'll keep that off refinement again
increases the range of the areas used to
create Reflections for us we can turn
that up to higher and it will create a
much better render Max lighting we don't
want to turn 3D mode on that's if you're
using a stereoscopic 3D viewing device
so you can actually look around if you
tick that you'll get some weird janky
exports such as don't tick 3D mode
unless you need it same kind of deal in
video tap it select all or individually
click on them one by one of what you
want choose your file format export of
course MP4 better than PNG considering
it is still unless you want 30 images
for every second of video Don't Hit PNG
frame rates completely up to you as the
editor of choice for me it's 30 frames
second I'm perfectly happy with that I
don't have to do anything so it actually
works really well with all my other
camera equipment
same details in the drop down menu video
mode you keep it on standard and
refinement you can Chuck it on high if
you want and of course Max lighting all
of these will significantly increase
your export time so just make sure you
turn them off if you want a quicker
render and of course decrease your video
quality if you want a quicker render as
well the one thing I failed to mention
is if you go back to your main menu
you'll see video one which produces the
file format again you can increase your
export times and your export quality by
simply going up to 8K it will take
forever 2K will be nice and quick so
just be mindful of what you're looking
to achieve and how quickly you need the
results
last but not least all you have to do is
come across the bottom hit the start
export button and your journey here on
Twin motion is complete anyway Zane
that's all from me I hope you've enjoyed
it so far I'm going to bring in the
playlist to the side of me so if you're
joining me a little bit later you can
find all the content right here
otherwise smash that subscribe button
drop any comments in the description
down below but like always I'll see you
next Monday